all right Adam is with us Adams in
Seattle
hi Adam how are you hi they it's nice to
speak with you and thanks for having me
on your show certainly how can I help ya
back in January I went to Vegas and I
want the money playing poker and with
you is I just wanna I'm just very
hesitant on spending this money I've
only spent it on once just to pay one
bill and just I just want your advice on
I'm just very hesitant on spending this
money I just want your advice of in
terms of purchasing and you know because
I know this money can go down the toilet
and down the tubes really fast so the
number one is the number one way it goes
back down the tubes for poker players as
they go back to the table exactly that's
the number one way you walked away from
the table at their proper at the proper
time apparently oh definitely yeah I
want 400,000 Wow you're good at this or
at least you were that day okay yeah
yeah well that's the best place to lose
it all to go back over there and do try
to do it again but anyway aside from
that the anytime you come into money of
any kind from anywhere what we tell
folks to do is just walk right up what
we call the baby steps and baby step one
would be to become debt-free except your
home do you have any debt other than
your home no just my home and I just
paid off my truck and that's the only
good for you this money that I paid off
so that's it okay that's finishes what
we call baby step to baby step three is
to set aside an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses and that's
that's grandma's rainy day fund in case
something bad happens and so what do you
make a year at your at your day job yeah
I'm a high school janitor and I make
twenty six thousand dollars a year how
old are you I'm 23 and you made 400
grand at the poker table yes that day
yeah Wow
honestly what a story okay life-changing
amazing well I'm glad that you're
paranoid that's you're wise beyond your
years that this scares the crap out of
you and that
wise beyond your years well done on that
okay so then the next thing I'm gonna do
is hold that emergency fund back and I
mean you can hold ten thousand bucks
back we'll call that your emergency fund
then we're gonna start investing fifteen
percent of our income do you own a home
no I I currently rent an apartment okay
if you want to buy a property this would
be the stage at which you buy a property
and we would tell you to pay cash for it
if at this stage of your life you're
ready to buy a property if not then you
may want to just start investing this
money I'll invest it very conservatively
which sounds weird to tell a poker
player that just made through four
hundred grand but I would stick very
conservatively and the way to do that's
just check in with one of our smart
investor pros they'll help you I'm not
in that investment business but I
endorse people that are happily and just
click it Dave Ramsey comm click on smart
fester they'll help you